I mentioned Bernie in an immigrants
level to the West because uh it boggles
my mind how anyone in this country takes
them seriously this is a guy who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union where he
would have had exactly the same
experience as every other Westerner
coming to the Soviet Union they would
have been they would have been taken to
some fake right wedding where fake KGB
agents were having a fake wedding and
then they would be taken on some kind of
trip every movement would be controlled
and these are the people who came back
from the Soviet Union I can't remember
if it was I I don't want to slander dead
people but I can't remember who it was
somebody one of these Darlings of the
left came back from the Soviet Union in
1938 as people millions of my ancestors
you know my countrymen and women were
starving and said I've never eaten as
well as I did in the Soviet Union
so let's throw actually to the to the
Oxford Union speech that you mentioned
because this how many views did this
thing get like it's hard to say probably
somewhere between 100 and 200 million
views yeah like across different
platforms oh lordy lordy all right let's
go and the only thing that wokeness has
to offer in exchange is to brainwash
Bright Young Minds like you to believe
that you are victims to believe that you
have no agency to believe that what you
must do to improve the world is to
complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings
and we on this side of the house are not
on this side of the house because we do
not wish to improve the world we sit on
this side of the house because we know
that the way to improve the world is to
work is to create it is to build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours
to forget about that
thank you very much
the brainwashing element is is pretty
interesting of this that that that's
hard to get people out of they feel like
they have this kind of holistic world
view and that somehow everyone before
them was an idiot or a that's the
one I can't get over yeah to be honest I
think young people always think that
about other Generations that you know
that thing about when I was 20 my dad
was an idiot and by the time I got 40 he
really wisened up yeah like I think we
all experienced that at some at some
level so my issue is that you know look
culture is the brainwashing of of young
people that's what culture is it's a
passing down of certain values and
beliefs about what it is to be human and
how we ought to conduct ourselves right
that's why you have an education system
that's why you have cultural content
that's why we teach children certain
values we are quote unquote brainwashing
them my issue is is that
I I've never understood this you know as
a first generation immigrant I I sort of
people want to tell me that I'm a victim
and I've never understood and it doesn't
really matter if it's true or not what
matters is is it useful and that's my
issue with all of this stuff it's like
why are you teaching children
things that will make them fail why are
you teaching children things that will
make them hurt things that will make
them anxious things that will make them
depressed why are you not teaching them
look you believe in climate change go
for it right go and fix a problem to do
with that issue go and learn and study
for years and work hard and you know
what Melissa Chen I don't know you you
know who else she's a good friend a
wonderful person I love Melissa I think
it was her that tweeted out something a
long time ago she said you can't remain
woke if you build something whether
that's muscle a business or anything and
that's why I would challenge those young
people very bright young people at
Oxford they are the future whether you
like it or not they are going to be the
people running our countries right I
challenge them to recognize that if you
care about whatever the issue it is
you've got to fix it you can't just sit
and mop
were you shocked how many students at
Oxford are buying that stuff because
when I spoke there uh it was a lovely
talk and I did my thing and then there
was some q a and I was getting some
pushback on stuff but I didn't feel it
had fully sort of proliferated
throughout but I I get the sense that
it's deeper now that was that was
probably five years ago when I was on
tour yeah because he taught to say
because you you see you know 400 people
or 500 people who came to see the debate
so what what the mix of it is it's hard
to say I did you know the thing that
really I found very reassuring is I had
a few people uh people would know this
but the debate started like three hours
later than they should have done so we
ended up sitting in the pub waiting and
there was uh there was this girl who
came up to me and she could not believe
she said so do you think they're awoke
people in the UK
another one uh yeah and sure so you
think they're awoke people in the media
oh yeah and she was like so give me an
example and I give her an example and we
went we went round and round for an hour
anyway after the debate lady
after the debate she comes over to me
and asks for a selfie so you know we
gotta we gotta be we gotta be willing to
try to change people's minds and I I
have hope for young people uh because I
was young and stupid and probably I'm
still to some extent both of those
things
um and you know people are persuadable
and you persuaded me your guest
persuaded me and I believe that we can
persuade others what about the people
that are pushing it sort of I don't want
to say blindly but did you see a clip uh
about a month and a half ago on Real
Time with Bill Maher where he asked
Bernie Sanders if you know if he knew
the difference between equity and
equality did you happen to see that I
didn't see that one no so it's a really
incredibly enlightening moment do you
know the difference between equity and
inequality I mean it's basically saying
to him do you know the difference
between socialism and capitalism in
essence and Bernie fumbles fumbles and
then basically says I don't know and
Bill explains it to him and it's like
well wait a minute you you've been the
prime mover of these ideas from a from a
economic perspective at least I don't
think he realized how it was going to
become racialized and sexualized and
everything else
um but it was clear to me that he just
didn't even know what he was talking
about that doesn't surprise me I
mentioned Bernie in an immigrants level
to the West because uh it boggles my
mind how anyone in this country takes
him seriously this is a guy who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union where he
would have had exactly the same
experience as every other Westerner
coming to the Soviet Union they would
have been they would have been taken to
some fake right wedding where fake KGB
agents were having a fake wedding and
then they would be taken on some kind of
trip every movement would be controlled
and these are the people who came back
from the Soviet Union I can't remember
if it was I I don't want to slander dead
people but I can't remember who it was
somebody one of these Darlings of the
left came back from the Soviet Union in
1938 as people millions of my answers
you know my countrymen and women were
loving and said I've never eaten as well
as I did in the Soviet Union these
gullible clowns in the west who have
never experienced socialism have never
experienced communism who sell simple
but false ideas to people they don't
deserve to be taken seriously they don't
and they don't offer any solutions uh
the solutions that they offer will be
counterproductive and hurt people in
this country and around the world uh it
boggles my mind that people don't
understand that but they don't if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell